so yesterday was Memorial Day here in
the United States Donald Trump was at a
wreath-laying ceremony and I got a ton
of emails and a bunch of articles I read
arguing that Donald Trump was visibly
struggling to stand at a Memorial Day
event and that there is this sort of
weird way in which Trump seems to be off
balance and regularly recalibrating his
balance so I'm not gonna spend a ton of
time on this if you know my show you
know we've covered Trump's strange
behavior whose sources we've never yet
determined we've not yet determined and
I'm gonna talk about that a little bit
let's let's first look at the videos and
then I'll tell you what I think here's
one video during a rendition yesterday
of the national anthem and Donald Trump
does seem unable to just stand up
straight his whole whole upper torso is
sort of rocking forward forward and back
as he's in a salute position and it
wasn't a windy day reports are that wind
was only four miles per hour no one else
is swaying in that way and that was the
source of some of the concern here is
another video from yesterday in which
Donald Trump walks up to a wreath and is
staring at it and again he's kind of
swaying in the wind sort of swaying back
and forth and he does at moments seem
like he's going in the direction of
falling over but his balance system
realizes it and compensates by pulling
him back so I want to be like a hundred
and ten percent crystal clear this could
be something or it could be nothing and
we've sinned we've seen this type of
stuff since day one with Trump these
inner ear balance type issues can be
related to all sorts of different things
in earlier stages sometimes even before
other dementia symptoms develop starting
to have issues balancing when standing
or walking can suggest an increased
potential to develop Alzheimer's or
other types of dementia balance issues
can be related to medication side
effects people speculate that Trump
takes stimulants stimulants can
certainly affect your balance but they
can also simply affect your
to sit still because you're energized in
this way that uppers stimulants and
amphetamines can do this could also be
Trump's weird stance I know some of you
are aware that Trump stands in a very
weird way kind of hinged forward at the
at the hips um that might make it
difficult to stand still there's
speculation that Trump stands that way
because he wears lifts in his shoes
which sort of lean him forward what we
know is this is not new what we know is
it wasn't windy yesterday Trump wasn't
getting blown around by wind so if you
say to me do I think something is up
here big picture you all know I think
something's up and I don't know if the
video from yesterday is part of it or if
it's something new or if it's nothing if
you say do I really care well I care if
it's something that's impacting Trump's
cognition because he's the President of
the United States whether or not
something like this explains Trump's
behaviors and actions Trump has failed
either way right
like the coronavirus response has been a
failed response whether or Trump has
dementia an inner ear issue is abusing
drugs or whatever the case may be it
could be ADHD right I mean if maybe
Trump can't stand still but does a good
job because he has ADHD and it's hard
for him to stand still who cares right
the point is he's not doing a good job
and he can't stand still and looks
unstable and looks confused and got off
of Air Force One and didn't recognize
his own limo in front of him and
wandered off until a Secret Service
agent brought him back holding him is
that why he's a bad president no he'd be
a terrible president no matter what the
explanation is does it aggravate the
lethality of this presidency yeah yeah
it probably does will we ever know
what's really going on here I don't know
I you know inside the Reagan White House
they knew while he was president that he
was starting to show signs and symptoms
of Alzheimer's it was learned sort of
officially publicly later only in
retrospect did people start
figuring out that it was not something
that happened only after he was out of
office he was experiencing symptoms
while he was in office my instinct is we
probably would not get anything
definitive about Trump while he is in
office it is yet another reason to get
him out in November meaning he would
leave in January rather than giving him
another four years hopefully someday we
do know exactly what it is that is going
on check this out the first 500 people
who see this video and go to david
pakman.com slash skill will get a
premium membership to Skillshare for two
months completely free skill shares the
online learning community with thousands
of classes on almost anything you can
imagine always taught by experts they
have classes on drawing painting
photography video editing web design
running a small business and much more I
recently took a very interesting class
called simple productivity how to
accomplish more with less and got a
bunch of great personal productivity
tips out of it we should allow ourselves
a little time every week to either get
creative keep your brain sharp learn
something new it's great for mental
health and almost all the classes are
under an hour so it's very easy for
someone who's busy to take advantage of
it with skill share you can discover a
new passion explore something you didn't
know you would enjoy but there's also
plenty of classes for people with
experience so you can just get better at
something you're already good at and
again the first 500 people who see this
video and go to david pakman.com slash
skill will get a completely free premium
membership for two whole months giving
you access to every class Skillshare
offers check it out I put the link right
underneath this video